الصراع بين الولايات المتحده والصين صراع
وجود بحسب لجنه فرعيه بمجلس النواب
الامريكي والتي دعت لمواجهه التهديدات
الصينيه اعضاء لجنه شؤون المنافسه
الاستراتيجيه بين الولايات المتحده والحزب
الشيوعي الصيني بالكونغرس حذرت حذروا خلال
جلسه استماع اوليه من التهديدات
الاقتصاديه والامنيه التي تشكلها الحكومه
الصينيه داعين الاداره الامريكيه للتصرف
بشكل عاجل لمواجهتها انطلاق اعمال اللجنه
ياتي في فتره عدم استقرار بين واشنطن
وبيكين وبعد اسابيع من تحليق
فوق الولايات المتحده في وقت يواصل فيه
النواب الجمهوريون مهاجمه الرئيس جو بايدن
بسبب رده فعله على حادثه منفض التجسس
الصيني شهدت اللجنه توافقا بين اعضائها من
الحزبين الرئيس الجمهوري للجنه وهو
عبر عن امله في ان تساعد اللجنه في تشكيل
سياسات وتشري عات تتعلق بالعلاقات مع
الصين يمكن لها ان تكسب تاييد الحزبين
مضيفا ان سياسه واشنطن على مدى السنوات
العشر القادمه ستمهد طريق لمئات الاعوام
القادمه على حد قوله
هذه ليست مباراه تنسين مهذبه هذا صراع
وجود حول الشكل الذي ستبدو عليه الحياه في
القرن الحادي والعشرين واكثر الحريات
الاساسيه على المحك
على الجانب الاخر قال النائب الديمقراطي
الرجاء كريشنا مرسي ان الولايات المتحده
تدافع عن مصالحها وانها لا تريد حربا مع
الصين فكانت بارده ام ساخنه ولا حتى صدام
حضارات اعتبر النائب ان واشنطن بحاجه
للتحرك سريعا لرفع مستوى التنافس مع بكين
والوقوف بوجهها
على مدى العقود الثلاثه الماضي يستهان كل
من الديمقراطيين والجمهوريين بالحزب
الشيوعي الصيني وافترضوا ان التجاره
والاستثمار سيؤديان حتما الى الديمقراطيه
وللمزيد من الامن بمنطقه المحيطين الهندي
والهادئ بما في ذلك جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه
وبدلا من ذلك حدث العكس
مع اقتراب الانتخابات الرئاسيه الامريكيه
العام المقبل ومحاوله الجمهوريين اظهار ما
يصفونه بضاع في موقف اداره بايدن تجاه
الصين الا ان عده ملفات متعلقه بكين اظهرت
شبه اجماع من الحزبين كالاجراءات التي
تحضر تطبيق تيك توك اضافه للحد من
الصادرات الامريكيه وتجاره التقنيه الى
الصين
قالت ان الخطابات والشهادات لم تكن جديده
الا ان اللجنه تهدف لارسال رساله قويه
للصين على صعيد الشارع اثار منتقدون
اللجنه الفرعيه بمجلس النواب مخاوف من ان
الخطاب التصعيدي الذي يصف الصين بعدو
الولايات المتحده من شانه زياده المشاعر
المعاديه للمواطنين الامريكيين من اصول
الاسيويه وبالتالي تصاعد نسبه حوادث
الكراهيه
نبقى مع التنافس الامريكي الصيني والى
مقال راي تحليلي نشرته نيويورك تايمز
فبحسب الكاتب وهو رص بابج الحرب مع الصين
لن تكون مثل اي حرب وجهها الامريكيون من
قبل الكاتب قال ان الشراره الاكثر احتمالا
لهذه الحرب ستكون غزو الصين لتايوان
واعتبر الكاتب ان الحزب الشيوعي الصيني
اصبح قويا بما يكفي على الصعود للعسكريه
والاقتصاديه والصناعيه للاستيلاء على
تايوان وتحدي الولايات المتحده بشكل مباشر
من اجل التفوق الاقليمي لكن لماذا ستكون
هذه الحرب حاله وقوعها مختلفه عن غيرها
بابج اضاف ان الامريكيين اعتادوا ان يرسل
جيشهم للقتال بعيدا عن الوطن الا ان الصين
كقوه قادره على نقل الحرب الى داخل
الامريكي عسكريا باستهداف البنيه التحتيه
الامريكيه وايضا بالهجمات الالكترونيه
وبالامكان ان تضرب الصين ايضا اهدافا
عسكريه للولايات المتحده في جغرافيا
حلفائها كاليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه وغيرهما
المقال قال ان الصين تعد الان القوه
الصناعيه العالميه المهيمنه تجاريا
وعسكريا وضرب مثلا بحرب اوكرانيا عندما
ادى تزويد كييف بالمعدات العسكريه الى
استفاد المخزونات الامريكيه لبعض الانظمه
العسكريه الرئيسه وهو ما قد يستغرق اعواما
لاعاده بنائها اضاف الكاتب ان حرب
اوكرانيا تعتبر صغيره نسبيا اذا مقورنت
بحرب كبرى في المحيطين الهندي والهادئ
[موسيقى]